[Music]
you work out so much you're dancing 24
7. so no wonder you have like the body
of your lifetime
i started developing a really unhealthy
view of my body
an eating disorder is different in a lot
of different ways you can something
about your body how you look what you
how you should eat you're counting the
calories you're
you're sizing up your legs and all those
different things you're just kind of
completely gripped by it and that's kind
of where i was
hey y'all i'm sadie robertson huff and
today i am unfiltered from my home
my makeup routine you know i will say it
fluctuates day to day
[Music]
and to be honest quarantine i don't do
a lot of makeup that's that's for sure
and that's kind of been a blessing
i think the first time i recognized
beauty and my aunt was in town and she
said
your mother is just exquisite and i said
what's exquisite mean and she said it
just means that she's just so
naturally beautiful and so i think i
noticed it most with my mom from my aunt
saying that and then my grandma
and my great grandma they were just my
pictures of beauty
[Music]
you know the biggest foundation in my
life
more than this foundation that is so
silly and doesn't last
uh would definitely be my family and my
faith
my family means everything to me my
husband is such a rock in my life he's
so solid he'll always be that
i know that if the whole world was
against me they would be for me
and my faith too i mean if i face planet
in front of the whole world tomorrow
i would depend on the solid foundation
of my faith for sure
so i grew up in west monroe louisiana
i actually grew up in a little bit
smaller town calhoun and
we always joke that there's more
chickens than people and that's just a
fact
i'm such a small town girl i love the
fact that
every time you go outside like if you go
to a restaurant you're going to see at
least three people you know
all right we'll probably go to blush
next give myself a little color
you sent 9 300 text messages in a month
is that bad you know being thrown into
the public eye
i think at any age is definitely crazy
but being thrown to the public eye when
you're a freshman in high school and
you are from a really small town it's
definitely crazy it's unheard of
actually doing it with my family made it
a whole lot easier
[Music]
so now i'm going to be looking back at
some of my favorite
and not so favorite duck dynasty moments
a little gas not that hard not that hard
not that hard
you know there are some milestones in my
life that definitely didn't make it on
the show
now i'm married i've started the
ministry that i
that i do now but at the time what i am
really glad that made it is when i
learned how to drive
terrible good gracious even though it
was so embarrassing at the time because
whenever you're 16 everything's
embarrassing right
and i was terrible in front of literally
the whole world watching
and it was just it was just bad
i danced with boys dance or let me dance
with beau
my boyfriend you have a boyfriend
yeah like yesterday my friend no
no no no i will say i did not want to
show
my boyfriend at the time who i was
dating on duck dynasty because
literally after we broke up forever
people would be like oh are y'all still
dating you're all still together and
then you're like
no we're not but he will always be known
as my duck dynasty boyfriend
i think sadie in real life is different
than patron on television because at the
time
on tv i think i was just a little bit
more nervous
in real life i am like straight up
goofball
are we just gonna play it was funny i
remember the first episode that i
watched i was like so
embarrassed i was like my voice is so
country
and since then i've gotten a lot more
confident in who i am and
the voice that the lord gave me
all right guys i'm gonna be talking
today about responding to the call of
god on your life okay
my journey with my faith is the biggest
part of my story
faith is hugely important to me it's not
just important to me because
it was important to my family it was
important to me because
whenever i met jesus it like literally
changed my life
after dancing with the stars happened i
didn't know what i wanted to do honestly
i was in this place where like my life
just dramatically changed so much i went
from living in westminster louisiana
to now being on dancing with the stars
in hollywood with 20 million people
watching every week and
the spotlight just literally being on me
and there's a million beautiful things
that come with that
but a lot of other things come from that
too you know and for me i started
struggling with a lot of insecurity of
who i was because of a lot of people
telling me who i am and not
really feeling like that was me i
remember thinking these thoughts like
i don't know how to be that like famous
girl that everybody loves and like you
know
follows on instagram i remember praying
and saying god like i think you chose
the wrong person like i
this this makes me nervous like this it
makes me insecure this is not something
i'm thriving in
this is when i realized this is my faith
is actually going to be like everything
to me
the lord said something so sweet to my
heart i just felt like god was saying
like i'm not calling you to be this
perfect person
i'm actually just calling you to be a
sister and a friend or those who don't
have a sister and a friend
i can be confident because i was created
on purpose for a purpose
all of a sudden like i was so empowered
to do everything that i'm doing now
and that's just my story but man like
that's why my faith is so important to
me
i'm gonna do my eye shadow and this is
actually kind of fun because
this palette is the palette that i use
at my wedding
i used to struggle with anxiety so much
and it's funny because
it wasn't really until i caught it fear
that i
really tried to fix the problem
i say that because i think a lot of
times we can you know
fall on the excuse if you will of oh i'm
just an anxious person
[Music]
but for me i knew it was beyond that
like it was fear grouping my life like
you know it's a problem whenever you run
off of an airplane like make the pilot
stop and say i have to get up the plane
because i believe this plane is gonna
crash like
fear begins to drive your life i think
my
fear a lot of it was stemming from the
fear of
being alone um in a weird way
what if like everybody just turned their
back on me and like in that little like
lie of fear of like what if you're in
this alone
but again like my faith is what helped
me through that
but the most important thing in my heart
is god i wasn't actually given a spirit
of fear when i was created
but i was given a spirit of power and
love and a sound mind i can rise to that
it helped me start denying those fears
and those anxieties that would come in
my head and
know that like you know what i know that
i feel this way
but my feelings don't define what the
truth is in my life
[Music]
now i'm going to do my favorite part my
eyebrows
i don't know about y'all but i love a
good eyebrow
during days of the stars you work out so
much you're dancing 24 7. so no wonder
you have like the body of your lifetime
people started to come on you know you
look great your body looks great
and there were so innocent comments at
first like everything was great
but then whenever my body started
looking a little different that's when
the struggle came in
and there were people in my life who
were just really negative influences
that would say
things that were just not uplifting
about the way that i looked and how i
needed to maintain
the body that i had and it was so wrong
i mean at the time
i just was insecure and so i just
believed them and felt like oh i need to
push it
i started developing a really unhealthy
view of my body
an eating disorder is different in a lot
of different ways you can something
about your body how you look what you
how you should eat you're counting the
calories you're
you're sizing up your legs and all those
different things you're just kind of
completely gripped by it and that's kind
of where i was
and so you don't realize that like the
things you're struggling with you think
it's just about you but actually it
affects like a lot of other people
around you
um because you're not able to be the
person that is for the people around you
i pretty much just took the word as it
was from the bible it talks about how
you're beautifully and wonderfully
created
and i started like praising god and
thanking him for the way that i looked
instead of looking in the mirror and
saying oh i wish my arms were thinner i
wish my legs were more toned
i wish i had her eyebrows i wish i had
her
waistline i wish i had a better thigh
get whatever it was that
i would tell myself instead of like i
wish i'd just be like you know i'm so
thankful that i have this i'm so
thankful
that my legs actually serve the purpose
that they should and that they're able
to run
that my arms are able to carry things
that you know my stomach could one day
hopefully be able
to carry a baby like just actually what
we're actually designed and created for
and it definitely made me start to stop
thinking about myself as much actually
and be able to think about others and
how you can actually serve others with
the body that you've been given
it's crazy when we think about that
really
having a big social media following
comes with good and bad
for sure i think the best thing about
having a social media following
is because so many people that you can
encourage and influence and
be a light to like that's that's amazing
i do not overlook that gift a single day
of my life
the bad thing about having social media
following also is kind of the same thing
there are so many people
and so many people have so many comments
about every single thing that you do and
that can be hard
this is what i truly believe honestly is
that you know
we live in a you've heard a cancelled
culture you know somebody says something
you disagree with you cancel them
you unfollow them you block them you
don't want to listen to them
and i think we got to be better you know
than that i think you know we
we got to rise above those differences
in the sense that like it's okay that
somebody disagree
disagrees with you it's okay that
somebody thinks a different thing from
you but i would hope that
people would be a little bit more kind
to not just feel like
oh you don't agree with me block cancel
it's like oh you don't agree with me let
me hear you out and and saying that i
got to do the same for other people who
might disagree with me
my makeup tip i'm a pretty casual makeup
goer i will say i have watched all the
youtube videos trying to learn i just do
a little curl
and this thing takes it away i'm telling
you i love marc jacobs
i've had so many fan letters and
messages and posts that i've been tagged
in that have truly like stopped me in my
tracks
um i've had one girl actually
it was the craziest story i was um
writing my book live
i was on my last day to write the book i
was up late it was like one in the
morning
because it was like late i needed to get
that book and turned in tomorrow and i
was not quite there yet
and i was writing about choosing life
and if you're on the brink of death and
if you're considering that your life
isn't valuable i need you to rethink
it because your life was created for
purpose on purpose all these things
as i'm typing it i felt the weirdest
thing in my heart kind of talked about
the lord speaking it's not like it was
audible i just felt it in my heart that
i needed to go check my instagram dms
and
i looked at my messages and i had a
message just come in and it said hey
sadie um i just wanted to let you know
that i'm gonna take my life tonight i
saw your message
on youtube you preaching and it really
encouraged me
and i want you to know that before i
take my life that i did watch that
i don't know why i'm messaging you to
tell you that she said but keep doing
what you're doing it's making a
difference in the world
and i was like oh my gosh when you find
love you find your purpose
your purpose is to love no matter where
you
are and so i messaged her real quick and
i said hey
i hope i caught you in time but please
let's reconsider like
i want i would love to chat with you and
she said i can't believe you just
responded i'm literally sitting here
with my phone in one hand and a bottle
of pills in the other
so we all have influence and when
somebody is
following you in their life you never
know
when they come when they come to you
what they're going through
when i think about my influence or my
fame and my following
that's what i think about like the fact
that i had a girl message me at two in
the morning telling me
thank you for the impact you made on my
life that's about to end and i was able
to encourage her
back to life
sorry i know i went so deep while we're
doing our makeup
in quarantine this truly is unfiltered
now we are continuing our marc jacobs
train this is not sponsored
ah not an ad i wish i spoke up to guys
that i did in the past who just didn't
treat me right to be honest
i wish i spoke up to the guy who was
constantly talking about the way that my
body looked and could be better
and if i would have just spoken up for
myself or stood up for myself that would
have sent me a lot of hurt
however you do grow from those things
and now that i'm married to christian
who
is just the most encouraging and
affirming person ever
finding your voice in those times will
save you from
a long couple of nights of crying
it's just life okay all done with my
makeup
beauty has evolved for me um i think in
a couple different ways in my life i
think just the maturity of how i see
beauty has grown a lot
i think a lot of times we say we want
inner beauty but we
seek to strive for our beauty what
really helped me with
the evolution of beauty is understanding
that it's not actually about being the
most beautiful person in the world
it's about the beauty that radiates from
the inside of you and off of you and
how that can actually captivate somebody
attention who loves you
think about that with faith too there's
a lot of beautiful things in the world
there's a lot of attractive things in
the world but i am
captivated by god i am captivated by
faith i'm
captivated by my family by my husband
and therefore i don't have to go and
wander out in the world to these other
things because i'm content
and what i'm captivated by and i think
that's one of those beauty tips for me
that has stuck with me and that has
actually made me more confident than the
makeup on my face ever will
[Music]